thank you hi everyone my name is Alamos
woody I'm from to cook say hi and
together with my
working on model using multiple
modalities to analyze video content I
will be talking about a few different
things so to make it more clear here's
an agenda my first year I will introduce
you to the problem so you can feel what
we was feeling at the beginning and
later it will about the data about
modalities that we are using how the
project evolved to the point where we
decided to use multiple modalities how
we combine them and finally we will tell
you tell you about some technical issues
that we had and how we solve them so
everything started this year's spring
when Nick the head of video editors from
media company that we work for asked us
if we can produce an automated solution
that would tell him what he should not
include in his videos so more people
watered until the end so here we have an
example there are some five four types
of food some look better some less
visually appealing
like for example that drunken chicken
marked with the red frame so basically
what Nick was just wanted us to do was
to analyze thousands of Facebook videos
and tells him that he should not show
drunken chicken tuna that gets at the
Terra unfortunately we can't tell Nick
that we that he can't show anything and
that drunken chicken is responsible for
anything because we can't analyze
causation but what we can do is to
analyze a correlation with what was
shown in videos and the retention data
and what is retention data there may be
slightly different definitions but in
our project we used this one which is a
fraction of viewers watching video over
time so let's say that 100 people start
watching a video and in the next point
only 50 of them are still watching so
the retention at this point is 0.5
I told you that we can analyze
correlations so what kind of
correlations we have videos which are in
fact venge of static images called video
frames so we want to take these video
frames apply in our own Network and
predict song retention data so we have
retention problem here that we want
regression problem that we want here to
solve and here's the actual retention
data from Facebook maybe is not exactly
important here what it means I will tell
you later about this but what is
important here is that the general
feeling about the data so at the
beginning you have really hard drop
which is expected because when people
watch Facebook movies they need some
time to decide if there are any way
interested in this movie and if there
are not they'll just scroll down to the
other video and later this magnitude of
drop decrease for a while and then you
have second sharp drop what you don't
want because it means that before that
drop something happened something that
people who were already interested in
the video didn't like so our idea was to
find such points and mark them for Nick
easier said than done because what
Facebook give us Facebook divides videos
into 41 equal parts and report number of
views for each of these parts and then
of course divides these numbers by the
tone by total number of views which by
the way you find in the official
documentation for unknown reasons we had
to ask faceboo developers directly to
get this information so what we have we
have 41 discrete points but we want to
analyze specific places in videos so we
in fact need continuous data so now it
seems obvious that we should you
somehow some kind of interpolation but
it took us a while before we move to
that point and forget about Facebook
format for good so you already have
continuous data but still there are some
problems because to tell that retention
drop is higher low we have to compare it
to something and it's not clear what we
should actually compare because first
problem is that people may behave
differently depending on what part of
video they are watching as you said
before at the beginning we may expect
some large drops but we don't want them
towards the end of the video so we can't
create any kinds of thresholds and say
that above a given number drop is large
but below is acceptable and the second
problem is that videos may have
different lengths so we can't compare
first second of 30-second videos to the
first second of two hours video because
there are basically different entities
and naturally we can't use raw data
forced out from Facebook for the same
two reasons so the actual procedure was
quite complex so you've got
simplification so let's say that we have
some point of the interest and the
retention value at this point is zero
point seven so you calculate a retention
drop from that point and then we
calculate rotation drop from drops from
the same rotation value for all other
videos in our data set which gives us
some distribution and then we can just
find you find in which percentile our
drop calculated in the first step is
placed so what it gives us is that we
can assign each point of the interest to
some value from range from 0 to 100 and
if it's not clear than sorry
it's my fault okay so you already know
what kind of target vulnerable we have
and now let's talk about the input data
so we have videos which at the very end
are just static images that we can
analyze separately so the image is our
first modality but on this images we
also have some text which tells stories
and we initially thought that these
texts are even more important than
visual information but unfortunately our
client don't have this text in any
editable format so we had to create our
own in-house solution to extract this
text from images which post some
problems because there were spelling
mistakes and it's a little bit hard
problem to know as videos to extract
text from them before moving father we
perform some basic experiments to check
what we can achieve with single
modalities and if there is any benefit
in combining them so as you can see when
we are using output from record source
trained on individual modalities we
achieved better results but before we
decided to actually combine this model
design use both of them we focused only
on text so we had an idea that we may
find some phrases or even individual
words that are correlated with better
good rotation unfortunately it didn't
work we tried to group word text
associate associated with better tension
and with good rotation and then
extracted key words from them and try to
compare them manually but we couldn't
find any meaningful patterns in there so
at this point we decided to use also
images but still even for human it'd be
difficult to decide if given image with
single text is anyway related to some
kind of rotation
so in the final solution we decided to
use sequences of images and text which
is our final input okay so we already
know that we want to describe our data
points with two types of data which and
four text part we have a vector from
fast text to elevate for T's from these
misspellings from OCR and from the image
we have features from ResNet fifty
Network but still we have two vectors
and we need only one so we have to
combine them somehow and what we can do
the easiest thing that we can do is to
just concatenate two vectors or glue
them together to achieve one long vector
which is very straightforward and easy
to implement but there are some problems
the first problem is that we make our
data more sparse so we in fact should
use much larger data set to make it work
well and the other problem is that our
model can't learn any meaningful
relations between these features but
still you can use this approach to Train
some basic models of so for example feet
SVM with this vector what we can do
better is to add another layer to that
content content vector which is
multi-layer perceptron which can combine
these features for us in some nonlinear
way and then we can use that
representation to train our regressor
and it's efficient and works quite well
but still we wanted something more fancy
so we implemented solution from last
year's paper called tensor fusion which
here you've got in simplified version so
the idea is that you have two or more
vectors you append values of one to them
it's a very important step because when
you later calculate outer product of
these vectors in the resulting matrix or
tensile on the edges you have your
original vectors and in the middle you
have linear combinations of these
vectors so your model can learn to put
more wave to any of the input or
combinations of them and it's also very
easy to train and efficient solution
another another solution that you can
use is how to encoder so it was like you
have two vectors you first concatenate
them and on the odd would you want your
original vectors back so that hidden
layer should learn certain code
information the compact way is in such
that you can actually retrieve all the
information from it so it sounds that
that hidden layer should make perfect
feature vector for your model so here's
our final solution and it will become
more complex than that diagram that
you've seen before because we are using
this equation that also we had to
somehow modify that idea to join
together so to operate on a four
dimensional data and join them together
and of course you can also train your
aggressor simultaneously who did with
this architecture by just using
additional output from that combined
modalities layer and it only drawback of
distortion is that takes a long time to
Train and also as you can use in your
project is that if you have some values
in a specific range at the output it may
be a good idea to actually modify
activation function from the last layer
so your model directly predicts values
the range that you want and it's easy to
that to do that we compared our models
using cross-validation which I highly
recommend because it prevents from
overfitting to the training set but of
course it takes more time and still it's
important to have some test set that you
don't touch to the very end and as you
can see after encoder worked the best
and concatenation gave us even worse
results than simple motors trained on
separated modalities so the conclusion
here is that if you have multiple
sources of data that are somehow
complementary it's good idea to try to
use them all but simple concatenation
may be not enough and you should
experiment with more sophisticated ways
on combining or mixing them together and
as promised here are some technical
issues that we had maybe the first one
isn't so surprising for you because
today's data sets are live large and
they're rarely fit into the memory but
still if you run into this problem I
recommend using a GTF file format and
the generators to read that bye-bye
batch from disk you can even do some
processing in these generators and it
still should work quite efficiently
another problem which was really
unexpected was Google cloud platform
maintenance policy because our virtual
machine was being restarted quite often
so we couldn't finish training in the
one run actually Google gives you $300
to try out their solution so it's worth
remembering if you want to use your
money for something meaningful and of
course we are using checkpoints but
still it was very troublesome to restore
experiments manually
well example you wanted to run some
experiments of over the weekend and on
Monday we discovered that nothing
happened actually
so wasting time on the solution here was
to use checkpoints and docker compose to
automatically rerun our containers with
experiments after it reboot and the
final problem that we unfortunately had
was represent the ability of our
research generating many data sets and
experiments and we couldn't
in fact recreate them later which is
probably general problem in research
community we tried some automated
solutions but they didn't work very well
and what work well was in fact creating
manual of readme files for each data
file generated which combined with
docker I stand for a mine environment
and source control version allowed us to
restore each experiments and recreate
each data set that we've created before
and also important is to actually not
only implementing this solution but to
check if everyone is following these new
rules so someone has to check if this
readme file actually being created and
thanks to my very fastest speaking
abilities the last was right and thank
you for your attention if you would like
to join our team we are hiring so check
out the website or contact me directly
so thank you
we have some space for questions so on
the model diagram you've shown that you
merge those two modalities only after
processing all of the frames by the lsdm
correct you mean that's right yes yes so
we are many merging in fact lsdm
representations of these input features
two vectors okay so have you tried to
instead merge those two modalities for
every frame separately and then running
this through the STM mm I guess not it
was wrong probably when you're creating
this architecture I think we additional
STM features are important to report
from rather technical context I think
there were not into the concept
conceptually but technically to make
this architectural work we needed that
additional STM features after input
vectors one more
okay
hello thanks for your talk I have a
question you you had a table comparing
the results of some methods and I want
yes yes and I wanted to ask you mmm can
you provide some intuitions why some
methods did better was I methods it
worse what was the what decided that
okay of course I can rephrase that
concatenation made our data even more
sparse so we simply had not enough data
points to make this ocean look good
that's why the results are so so bad and
other architectures were becoming
gradually more complex so I think it's
just quality of representation of these
two modalities which decided that some
results are better so in fact in
autoencoder we have very good
representation of these multimodal
features and that's why our aggressors
learn to correlate and to find these
correlations better than other
architectures